Unlike cut baby carrots, farmers grow “true”
baby carrots to be naturally small, or other
times they are simply carrots harvested before
they get a chance to completely mature.
“True” baby carrots bear the same cone
shape as a normal sized carrot while only
being a fraction of the size.
A number of farmers produce these type of
baby carrots when they thin their crops during
the growing season by removing a certain percentage
of immature carrots.
However, other farmers purposefully harvest
entire crops of carrots young in order to
sell the baby carrots with their green stems
attached.
That little detail allows growers to prove
that their baby carrots are “true” baby
carrots rather than carrots cut to look miniature.
The majority of baby carrots sold in supermarkets
are not this type, but are manufactured to
look a certain way.
The baby carrots that we know today didn’t
arrive in stores until 1989.
Successful carrot farmer Make Yurosek operated
a farm and processing plant in California,
and he believed that there had to be a better
way to use the 400 tons of carrot cull that
his plant processed per day.
Cull carrots couldn’t be sold in supermarkets
because they had issues such as being broken
or too misshapen.
There were times when as much as 70% of the
day’s processed crop ended up culled.
To solve the issue, in 1986, Yurosek experimented
in creating smaller carrots from the cull,
using an industrial potato peeler and a green
bean slicer.
When he sent them to a large west coast supermarket
chain to see what they thought, he received
a positive response.
“I said, ‘I’m sending you some carrots
to see what you think…Next day they called
and said, ‘We only want those.’”
The process of manufacturing baby carrots
has been refined and streamlined in the years
since Yurosek first created them.
At Grimmway Farm, one of the United States’
top carrot producers, full-size carrots are
planted close together in an effort to have
them grow straight and minimize the amount
of carrot that will need to be trimmed later
on in the process.
Then, a mechanical harvester harvests the
carrots and they are transported to the processing
facility where workers use hoses and water
to force the carrots out of the truck.
The carrots are then washed into the processing
facility on luges.
The luges, and the water, serve a dual purpose:
washing off the loose dirt and sanitizing
the carrots with trace amount of chlorine
in the water.
Next, the carrots are sorted before being
cut into 2 inch sections.
Grimmway Farm then stores the carrots for
one to five days before peeling them and rounding
the edges in a spiral slide made up of a grated
surface.
Finally the carrots are sorted one last time
before being packaged up and shipped to stores.
The extra carrot bits ground off during the
peeling process either end up as cattle feed
or become compost.
Concern arose over the past few years about
the use of chlorine in the manufacturing of
baby carrots.
A deluge of chain-emails were sent about claiming
that the baby carrots were soaked in a chlorine
bath and that the white blush that appears
on the surface is the chlorine coming to the
surface.
In response, Bolthouse Farms, the other top
producer of carrots in the United States and
largest producer of baby carrots worldwide,
created a website in order to refute the rumors.
The truth is that the process is regulated
by the FDA and the amount of chlorine in the
water is approximately 90% less than the chlorine
level in regular tap water.
That minute amount of chlorine sanitizes the
carrots to prevent consumers from contracting
foodborne illnesses such as E. coli and Listeria.
Additionally, the white blush on carrots comes
from dehydration, rather than chlorine seeping
to the surface.
Soaking the carrots in water for a time will
typically cause the bright orange color to
return.